awesome hello everyone
everybody happy having a good conference
look at that amount of feedback i'm
getting i'm from sweden swedish people
don't give that much feedback
belgians don't give any feedback all
finns don't americans do
but you guys have been so good i'm
impressed um so we're gonna be talking
about asp.net core or owen or sort of a
combination
um
so who am i
some people say you don't need this
slide
if
yeah um the person that says that is
scott hanselman if you're scott
hanselman you don't need this slide if
you're me you need the slide
um my name is chris klogg i work as a
senior developer slash technical think
something
teacher mentor for a company in sweden
and i generally spend a lot of my time
sort of parting knowledge i go to
conferences and speak i mentor teams um
i've done a pluralsight course um i used
to blog a lot and i love sharing
knowledge in different areas that i've
figured out along the way um
any spirit mvp um asp insider all of
that little thing doesn't really matter
um the only thing that's quite important
is
i am from sweden so if you don't
understand what i'm saying
tough
um there's not much i can do about it
that's just the way it is
um
so the question is what is owen how many
of you are working with owen today
okay
how many of you could go up here and
explain what owen is
he he goes i i went into a stretch
[Music]
okay it's actually not that complicated
there is nothing there owen is a
specification right so the only spec
says owen defines a standard interface
between.net web servers and web
applications that is basically where it
is it's a piece of paper or a document
that basically says this is the way we
abstract away our web servers using a
simple interface and it means that
instead of having this where
if we're building web-based things
on.net we have to run it on iis
with owing we're basically saying no
we'll make it possible for you to run
net-based web applications on other
platforms in is
which is quite cool
except
how many of you guys are doing web
development today in asp.net
how many of you are not using asp.net
mvc
okay not even close to half of you so
the problem is that asp.net mvc is
actually tied into
ies completely
which means there's actually no way of
removing mvc out of iis and putting it
into owen or project katana in the
current version but
asp.net core gives us that ability
so the idea behind the um
the om pipeline is that we have this
company called an app funk
that funk is the abstraction between the
web server and your application so the
web server will do the thing of
accepting your request and pull it apart
and take all of that information into
put into dictionary
pass it into something
through the app func
and that app func then returns a task
back and the web server sits there and
waits for the task to complete and when
the task once the task is completed it's
done
so that is the abstraction we're getting
so it the whole thing pretty much inside
owen is that one delegate
and a dictionary
this by the way the dot on requesting is
sevdo code it's not there's nothing that
you can run like that but that would be
sort of the idea behind it the server
will go when i get a request pull it
apart put it into the dictionary and put
the send the dictionary into the app
func
the app funk then has a friend
called the mid funk
the mid funk is not actually in the spec
today it's a it's a draft 1.1 or
something like that of the o inspect
and it basically defines how do we add
things to this incoming and outgoing the
request pipeline because right now with
in owen they specify and say the app
func is the way that the server calls
into our application
and then you will build some form of
pipeline that we will send the request
through and then when it comes back we
will we will send response back but
somewhere in the middle they sort of
forgot how to go from this into building
a pipeline
so everyone did their own version of it
or the few people that did build this
actually built their own version of it
so they decided that we're going to have
another funk
which is a if you see they're using mid
funk equals it's a funk that takes an
app funk and returns an app funk
it's getting ridiculously complicated to
figure this out after hand you'll see
when i remove sort of the syntax like
this and you'll see me building stuff
you'll see it's actually not that hard
but it's good to know that you've got
the app funk and the midfunk
so if we look at what's actually
happening in owen you get this process
called some process.exe it's a host
the host can be anything in owen it can
be a console app it could be a windows
service it could be iis it can be
anything it's a host
you can literally plug it into your wpf
application and have your wpf
application act as a web server
for some reason
not saying that that would be very
useful but you could
inside the host you have a server
we split this into think two different
things so you've got the host that will
just host it and you have the server
which will open the port and listen for
incoming requests and then handle all of
the http communication with the client
and the reason is that it basically
makes it easier for us to pull and
things apart and plug different things
in
if you're running this in iis which you
can iis will both be the host and the
server so its a one one package deal but
when you're building in a command line
application for example you will have
the host being the exa file and then
you'll pull in another server that will
do the actual communication for you
inside the server we have a pipeline
the pipeline consists of middlewares
pieces of code that will execute as the
information goes in and out of this
pipeline
and we have an application
the thing that organizes the response
creates the response that we need to
send back
and if you don't want to code all the
way down into this raw framework which
basically you get
incoming requests here is the path i
requested here is this your request this
is the information and you have to do
everything manually you will build some
have some form of web framework that you
would put on top of it that will do it
for you something like nancy fx or fubu
embassy or something like that that
works with owen
so you get a client client connects to
the server right it creates a request
and it's a simple get http one one
request
sends over some information and says
this is the path i want to use it's a
host i'm requesting and all that
server takes that request and pulls out
the parts in that http request and puts
it into a dictionary
the dictionary is of string object so it
means that you can conclude include
everything which is kind of cool because
it means that inside that dictionary we
can include strings like the path i've
requested the user agent string and
everything but we can also include
things like the stream the incoming
stream in an http post or the outgoing
response stream as well so we can put
stream objects in the dictionary
and that's the way that we communicate
with the client when we're sending back
responses
but we can also put in
delegates so we can put in application
delegates in this thing and basically
say here is a function that i put into
this dictionary with this name and if
you want to do something pull out that
function and pass values to it so we can
actually pass not only data but actually
functionality through a dictionary as
well
does that make sense
there's a sample that's actually in
there so um owen has an extension where
you can you can add owen extensions and
one of them is file send
so if you want to send the file in owen
there's one way of doing it is opening
the file reading the file from disk and
then streaming it to
to the client
through the stream
but most web servers actually have a
built-in functionality
to serve up files so iis has a very
optimized way of serving a file so there
is an extension to owen that says you
can if your server supports it add a
dictionary key that is
owin.file send or whatever like this
that returns a function
you take that function and you pass it
the path of the file and then the the
web server does the rest for you so you
can pass functionality and the web
server can actually add functionality to
your owen pipeline in an agnostic way so
you can have a look at it and say if my
web server supports this feature i can
use it if my web server doesn't support
this feature then i have to do something
else
does this make sense
very simple abstraction
it the server then takes the dictionary
sends it into the pipeline it hits the
first middleware
first middleware does its thing it can
be anything
it passes it on to the next middleware
and it passes through all the
middlewares in the pipeline until it
reaches the application
the application looks at whatever is in
the dictionary and figures out that okay
so he's requesting xyz with these
parameters i need to go and do this
thing here and then i'm going to
generate some html and then i'm going to
post that back to the client
as soon as i set send something in to
the response stream
i notify the server and say i am now
writing things to the stream
and the server automatically sends all
of the headers and it sends all of the
data and starts streaming the data back
to the client
at that point as soon as you've written
anything to the response stream you
cannot modify any headers you cannot
make any changes to the response stream
they are already on the way to the
client
you can get notified if your middleware
needs to know it can get notified that
this is happening
the server then takes whatever is coming
back and says okay so you have started
writing your body that's fine i will now
take all of the headers that are have
been configured i will generate an http
response with all the headers in there
start sending down that down the wire to
the client and then i'm going to
keep on
feeding whatever you're pushing into the
stream i will just keep streaming down
to clients make sense
hope so it kind of should
and that then goes back to the client
client is happy it gets a web page
but then it goes back again so basically
the dictionary then goes back out again
so it goes from the application to the
middleware too and then it goes from
middleware to middleware one
which then goes and sends it back to the
server or rather notifies the server
that now all the middlewares have been
able had looked at it on the incoming
and outgoing and i am now done with the
whole request and the server can then go
and terminate the connection and
basically say the response is now done
that is a win
and i guess most of you have heard of
project katana or katana project
katana project is microsoft's owen
implementation so it basically microsoft
took a look at owen and said this is
pretty cool we'll build our
implementation of it they made some
tweaks to it they made some
modifications to in typical microsoft
spirit we'll take what is there and then
we'll make that and then something else
but they kept in line with what's in the
specs so actually
all of their modifications could
actually still go under the owing
specification properly
so
the the change that they did is that
they instead in the app func here you
see func i htp context and task it used
to be i dictionary of string objects so
they added a little layer on top of the
dictionary to make it easier for us to
get access to the response stream and
the request stream and the path and all
of that without having to know all of
these dictionary keys
and then it still supports the
dictionary syntax where you can go
context.environment
and then you get the dictionary and you
can go and add and read things from the
dictionaries you want it's just that
microsoft thought it was nicer to get a
typed statically typed interface for you
to work with than a dictionary which i
find
quite obvious
then comes along asp.net core one i
think that was the final name of it
after all of the other things it started
out with k
somebody gave me access to k before it
was even announced before tech ed
when they announced it because i was
doing some stuff that kind of
had nothing to do with k at all but i
thought i'd want to look at it i went in
i looked at it and i
understood nothing it's not easy when
you get a nougat or a github project
with all of that in it and you sort of
go okay
it changed a whole lot of things i just
gave up i didn't look at it and then i
it went from k which was a fantastically
ungoogable name
k
throwing error
duh
okay
that goes into asp.net v next became
asp.net five and then that turned into a
speed and had core one and all that and
we're now at asp.net core one
core one has a pipeline
the pipeline looks a lot like owen
but it's not owen
the idea is there
the functionality is the same but what
they've done is instead of having i
dictionary or string object they are
doing an http context
http context is not a tiny little shim
over a dictionary it is a statically
typed object it's not an interface it
doesn't support a dictionary syntax at
all it is a new object so they are
breaking the oem spec there but it's
actually easier to work with this thing
so i find it actually quite okay
it's still you can still mock it you can
still new up that thing you can still do
all the testing you want with it but
that's the big change so all the places
where you see i dictionary in owen you
will see hp context in here instead
so let's have a look at getting started
i
considering the speed of internet in
australia
yeah ouch i used to live in new zealand
i know exactly how poor it is so i i've
started up the project before because i
want the nougat packages to get
installed properly and not sit here and
wait and restoring so what we get here
this is quite uncomfortable um it's a
simple empty asp.net core
web project using the.net framework i
could have gone with core but i went
with net because i have a other demo
later on that will include some net
stuff it starts out with this
main method i guess everyone has seen
core by now right anyone not seen core
okay cool so there's a project program
static void main then there's a startup
file
which is exactly the same as you would
have had in project katana there's a
class called startup but instead of it
being dynamically loaded when iis starts
up or your app starts in is it's
actually they point at it
here so you give it the class name there
there are no cloud there are no
attributes there's nothing else it's
just you have to put it in there
and the other difference is that there
are now two methods you need to
implement or you should implement
one is configure
which used to be called configuration
um i application builder as the first
parameter used to be iap builder they're
like tiny little variations between
katana and this if you look at the
syntax
um so that is the one that we're used to
but it also supports dependence
injection
which is why i can add other parameters
here like eye hosting environment and i
logger factory and all of that it will
be dependence injected
everything in astr net core includes
dependency di
and di is set up in the configure
services method
that takes an iservice collection where
you're basically going to say i want to
add a service with this interface here's
the implementation and you're good and
it starts doing everything for you so
that's the main difference
and if we look at
i'm just going to scroll down focus on
this part here
this is pretty much our our pipeline our
app
so we can go here it looks to see if
we're in development mode then use a
developer exception page
otherwise just go and say app.run
run means i will return a response i am
the end of the pipeline there's nothing
after me i am the final stop and when i
if i'm not returning a response
everything is broken
so that doesn't take a reference to the
next middleware it just takes the
context and then you say context dot
response rate is write async hello world
pretty simple i go ctrl f5
i hope this works because it's not this
is microsoft template it should sort of
work out the box it's slr world
nobody's impressed
um
hard crowd no i seriously i know i know
it's not impressive but it's kind of it
shows how simple everything is
so we can go in and say app.use instead
use is saying i have a middleware i
might return a response or i might just
pass it on it's kind of like a i had a
friend that i showed this to the other
day because he hadn't worked with with
this before and i said russian dolls
actually makes a lot of sense it's like
a russian doll you pass things in
through the dolls the outer layer passes
it to the inner that pass it to the
inner that passes it in there and
somewhere it changes and goes back and
it basically goes out all the layers
until it exits the doll again makes
sense
it's the only time i will use a doll as
a reference for anything while doing a
presentation
next you get these two there are two
ways of calling calling use there used
to be only one but microsoft decided
that that whole mid funk that is going
into owen
should go in here as well it's not a
proper mid funk because it uses
the the wrong app func but it has the
same idea it takes an app func and
returns snap func but
the one that you're used to seeing
looks something like this async
ctx
this is going really good
next
how many of you have seen this before
how many of you you said you had worked
with
owen and there's like one hand that goes
up have you seen this this is owen 101
it's not even that this is like beyond
101 this is what i expect you to know
when you come to class
um so i'm just going to ctx dot
response
dot write async and i can go hello
and dc like that
and if i
compile this
it should sort of just work it does whip
to do i've made no difference except the
fact that i've now made this thing
completely useless
because i'm always returning a response
but what if i want to do something else
what if i want to go inline what if the
whole thing of russian dolls and i'm
talking about the pipeline and all i'm
doing is returning it so instead of that
i can go ahead and i can do something
like this
so let's pull out that actually let's
not let's not do that i want to do this
app.use let's check the other syntax
this this is going to give me a kick i'm
going to see how many of you are going
to look at this and go
what
it's going to be next
fat arrow
async
i really can't spell
ctx fat arrow
thing
does that syntax make sense
there's a guy going yes
is there anyone that agree with me that
this syntax does not make sense
thank you there's at least one honest
person in here i looked at this and i
went what
it's not that complicated it does make
sense it does it's basically
it's it's a funk that takes
the next middleware reference as a
parameter but that func in turn returns
returns another func that takes the
context
so it basically just becomes two fat
arrow functions after each other
it's apparently very logical then we can
say var
timer equals new stop
stopwatch like that timer dot start
await
next
it wants the context let's pass it into
context so that's where this before
doing the call to the next this is on
the way in through the pipeline then i
go and i wait the next one which passes
the whole thing back back into the
pipeline through the pipeline and then
when it comes back from next i'm on the
way out so i can go and say timer dot
stop
and then i can say console
dot write line i can use this funky new
syntax
and say request
to
ctx dot request
request dot
path
took
timer
dot elapsed milliseconds i am a really
slow type where i figure out especially
when i'm standing
weirdly there it is
so i stop my timer and i write at the
request through console the problem now
is that the console doesn't actually
work if you put it through is express
because there's no console in there it
will just swallow it so i can go up here
and i can switch it and say i want to
run it as a console app instead and i
can go f5
it goes up and it goes hey
hello ndc which is quite cool not
but the interesting thing is here
so i get all of these so basically i'm
now measuring the time it takes for all
my requests to go through and it's just
an inline thing so basically
methods go or incoming requests go
through me and on the way out i do
something else so we got this awesome
pipeline everybody's going it's not very
impressive no it's not very impressive
it's actually very low level not very
complicated at all but it gives you a
lot of power to go this deep
how many of you have built um
i http modules before
or i http handlers for iis
how many enjoyed it
exactly
this is the same thing it's just that
this is actually quite enjoyable because
it's simple and it's not is dependent
there's one little thing um writing to
the console is a pretty bad practice
right so what we want to do since we
have dependency injected the i logger
factory we can go and say
no
var logger equals
logger factory dot create logger name it
request
timer
like that and then we can say logger
dot
log
information once i've done that i
actually do get color coded messages so
i get little green thing
that says info and it's more structured
it's is structured so i can go in and
see it's it's information and it's from
the request timer
and it took that long
nobody's impressed okay
well
that's what you get for trying to be
nice
so
it's all very very simple right
uh but that's also kind of the problem
do you want to build all your
applications like this like inline
methods for everything
so looking at this you sort of go oh
that is ugly i really don't want to go
and do this full time
so you really need to go and get
organized when you're building your
middlewares you cannot go and just build
inline functions it's just it's going to
look like crap and you're going to end
up just going to be ugly but then
somebody's going to go that's not a
problem i can just do a static class and
i can put my functions in there and it's
going to be awesome
yes and no
so you need to make sure that you are
structured if you're gonna do owing
stuff and one of the things is that we
build middlewares middlewares don't have
to be inline functions and i really
don't think unless they're very very
simple ones like
this
it shouldn't be an inline function can
we agree on that
good if not there's the door
and if i ever end up on a project with
you guys and i see in line one i'm gonna
hunt you down
so i'm gonna add a middleware
folder like that and i'm gonna add a new
middleware so i'm just gonna go and add
new class
request timer middleware
like that remove all of that stuff
i'm going to add a constructor in here
constructor is going to take a request
delegate
which is
a core specific thing it's similar to
owen and i'm going to call it next i'm
going to store that in a variable like
that
i'm going to add another method down
here called public
async
task
yes
invoke
the invoke takes a
http context
like that
then i'm going to go out here and i'm
going to pull out this thing here
that was wrong key combination there it
is
there is i'm going to fix this i'm going
to slowly going to fix this let's go
like that so it's going to say next
isn't available that's fine it's
underscore next because the reference
comes in through the constructor and not
as a part of this function call
then it's going to say i can't access
loggerfactory
i can solve that because this thing
supports
dependence injection so i can just go in
here and ask for a logger factory
but i'm actually going to go and request
an i logger instead because one of the
things with the di here is i can request
the logger factory and create my logger
and i get an ilogger back of a specific
type or i can request an eye logger of
the right type to begin with so i'm
going to take this thing and i'm going
to tell it that this is the thing that
i'm logging for i'm going to call it
logger
i'm going to introduce logger
i'm going to
remove
that
and put it in there
and everything seems to work
slightly more struck
i don't like the fact that that one is
grayed out but i am calling it there
right yes
and why is that thing squiggly
i really hope this works it looks right
okay i'm just going to ignore those and
now that we've got those in our own
class we can actually just remove this
thing and say app.use middleware instead
and then i tell it that i want to use a
request
timer middleware like that
is that more structured
since i'm getting squiggly lines i just
want to press f5 and see if this
actually works
no i know i know i'm just i'm yeah it
seems to work i'm i'm getting uh timing
right
requests to blah blah blah took yeah it
seems work okay yeah i know i know that
there are some
yeah i don't know how to put this in any
other terms than bugs in in useful
studio when it comes to this
there is potential i think that's the
way you put it as a program manager
um
this looks clear cleaner right
but it's actually not that clean well it
is pretty clean but it's kind of
annoying because i don't like doing it
like this this looks quite cool right
so one of the things that we do with
with uh owen middlewares and also
middleweights here is that we actually
try to make extension methods for them
so they're easy to use and we have this
syntax of app.use whatever and everyone
is used to working with that so if we go
in here create a new class
i'm going to call it
request
timer middle
yeah middleware
extensions like that
and remove that into a new file
save that make this thing
public static class
public static i application builder
use request timer
like that it's going to be this
i application builder app
now we take this thing here no we take
this thing here
we do return
like that
and this is now the freaky part
i'm going to move this thing into this
namespace
like that
anybody know why
yeah it it it's an extension method to
be able to use your extension method you
have to do an import of your namespace
by putting it in that namespace that has
to be there because i application
builder is already is being used anyway
it means that you will automatically get
app.use request timer without having to
do a separate import or using
that looks pretty good right
okay
this is cool
until somebody goes and says by the way
i actually want to log something else i
want to have a different format of it
oops
so next step in this thing doing a
middleware is an options class and tell
it that i want to be able to configure
my middleware you use that or do that by
creating another class there are always
three classes involved there's a public
request timer
options
it needs to be class right
there it is
look at that that's beautiful
and then you add whatever functionality
you need whatever configuration you need
for your middleware you add here as
properties so i'm going to create a prop
that has the f
it's a func that takes an
um an
http context
along
and returns a string
and i'm going to call it format
there
i'm going to go in and create a
constructor i'm going to say format
equals and i'm going to create a new one
of these ctx
elapsed
now i'm going to take this thing here
and this thing here is going to change
into elapsed
does that make sense
okay i'm going to move that into a
different move that into a different
file to get it out of the way
i changed this thing here and i add
another parameter to my constructor i'm
going to say i need a request timer
options options
let's save that
save that as a variable
and then down here instead of logging it
straight like this i do options.format
and it wants a context so ctx and he
wants the elapsed time which is timer
dot elapsed milliseconds like that
okay
and finally and the last thing we need
to do
is in our use request timer i'm going to
say you have to be able to pass in a
request timer options
but it's not mandatory so it's optional
and then i pass that on
i am not doing this very well today
there it is
i passed that into my use middlewares
call which means that it's going to be
passed into the constructor
so anything you pass in here will be
passed in to your middleware after the
delegate
and then i'm going to say if it is not
provided i'm going to create a new new
of them and basically give it the
default options
and once that's done
i can go and say new
request middleware timer options
and say format equals
something useful actually it needs to
look like this ctx
elapsed
request
took
elapsed
ms
and if i run this now
it answers as it should
and if you go in here and have a look it
says request took zero milliseconds so
i'm now able to modify the uh the way
that i format it i can go in and make
different changes since i'm getting the
http context i could be logging in a
whole bunch of other things as well and
adding that to the string if i wanted to
and i can make more complicated things
but the most important thing is
when we're doing our middlewares we
should really be doing a middleware
class
an extension method and an options class
it might be that you go i don't need
options class just throw it in there
it's actually an empty way of passing in
an options class it's there and then if
you ever need to add something it's
actually quite easy to add it instead of
having to add the help file
does that look cool
so we need to keep simple right
we cannot build a whole bunch of things
using these middlewares easily
because as you see i forgot to show you
this but there's actually quite a cool
feature with this
you know this path
gives me exactly the same response
there is no path handling in here
there's no functionality this is the raw
version of everything so basically if
you need to do anything in here you have
to do it manually
so if you're going to build a website
that returns different files or
different responses for different paths
then you have to build your own little
thing that parses those paths and if
that is a big website that is going to
be a long switch clause
or something else
so it's very very simple
so we do need and go go and get help we
need to get other people to build the
stuff that we need right
so far we haven't done a whole lot with
project katana most people see owen
middleware in katana
when they do security or authentication
because all of your authentication
experts at mvc use this project katana
and the owing pipeline to plug in all of
their oauth stuff
but we can do much more but it's
basically the same idea if you want to
go and do something you can actually
actually in katana you can do web api
i i tend to host web api inside the om
pipeline quite a lot
so
we get other people to build our stuff
and we can go and have coffee and charge
the client for that no sorry i didn't
say that
it makes everything faster
no it's it's get other people to do your
work it's it's much easier i promise you
so either going nougat something or get
a slave
so what do we do if we want to do
something more complicated well we go
and find whatever
person that has built this awesome tool
that we want to use and obviously when
we come to asp.net core
we can finally use mvc inside the
pipeline so mvc is to opt
the
yeah whatever
sometimes my english fails me badly
um
yeah
nbc is the one that i'm going to be
using i was supposed to say something
else but yeah so i go out to project
jason i pull out microsoft
microsoft i don't know why that is
lowercase if anybody at microsoft
listens can you make that uppercase
first letter
thank you they're recording it that's
why i'm saying i hope that somebody
watches it so i'm going here a split
core
nvc
one zero like that
not very impressive but it means that we
can go in here and we can say
app oh
that that thing shouldn't be uppercase
app.usenvc with default route
if we don't do default route we have to
go in and do our rot configuration
manually with this thing we just get the
default one that everybody knows
and mvc actually needs a bunch of
services so they've been nice enough to
create an extension method to i-service
collection that is called add mvc
and there there it will add all of the
services with the default config and
then you can go in and pass in an
options class if you want to change the
configuration
with mvc in my pipeline i can now go and
do the stuff that we always do we go and
go folder controllers
go and say add
new item
i want to have something asp.net
let's do an mvc controller called home
let's clean it up because there's no
reason to keep that
there is it's beautiful right not going
to make any changes to it it's a clean
controller
what next else do we need we need a view
folder so add new folder
view
[Music]
we need to add another folder in here
add
folder
home and then you can see here we're
going to say add
new item
and we see layout page i'm going to call
it index
i'm going to take this and i'm going to
say h1 and i'm going to say hello ndc
from mbc
there it is
around this
kind of sucks that this has already been
shown like 90 000 times by damien
edwards and david fowler and nobody is
impressed that in about five seconds
my application will do an mvc
application in the console app which is
really really cool but they've destroyed
it already
but it works right so what we do is we
go ahead and we get our middlewares from
other people we let people like damien
and david go and build our stuff and
then we piggyback on it that's the way
we should be doing things
one thing to keep in mind which is a
little bit different here than it was
with project katana if i go in like this
and press enter i end up back at hello
ndc because mvc
we come into our pipeline it's actually
quite easy to have a look at this
let's just kill that we come into our
pipeline request comes in
it adds the exception page it goes to
request time or request time oh that's
kind of cool i didn't show you that but
the request timer actually works still
even though i'm all of a sudden doing
mvc stuff this thing still times
everything
so when when david goes up and says that
nbc is real as.net core is really really
fast we cannot prove that he's hopefully
right
then it goes through the the timer it
goes through mvc mvc will then look at
it and go that path is not something
that i recognize it's not part of the
path that i would expect so it passes it
on to the next one
uh in
if you were doing project katana you
could combine owen with mvc but what
would happen is you would have your owen
pipeline and if there was nothing that
responded in the om pipeline you would
actually fall out of the pipeline and
hit iis
is would then handle the request and do
the mvc stuff and then it would pass it
back but that also meant that if mvc
didn't find anything that at that path
it would return a 404.
in this case if it doesn't find anything
it just lets it follow through to the
rest of the pipeline
okay so
this is pretty awesome right
it is very very simple very very low
level it is very raw and awesome to work
with
it's it's fast it's easy to throw things
it throws things in there you do things
like oh i just want to see what this is
you do a little in-line thing you run it
you can debug it it's very very easy and
then if you want to go bigger you add
more
you can also fork the pipeline so
instead of doing use or run there's a
map and map when method and basically
you can say
when somebody comes in to this pipeline
and the url is this
i want to have this configuration of the
pipeline and these middlewares and
otherwise use these
which is really cool because it actually
opens up a scenario that i've been doing
a few times and people look at me
weirdly when i do i do different
authentication methods
so i have an application where we split
the application into three different
pipelines
one pipeline will run an
mvc website that uses
login i think they're doing social
logins through through facebook
so they will use cookie authentication
then i have another part of the website
that starts with slash api which is for
a web api and that thing will not use
cookies it will only use
access tokens so it will use better
tokens
and then i have another partner website
that goes to slash and it's an admin
part of the section thing that couldn't
use social logins but uses their
internal logins instead so they have a
different login there but they're still
using cookie authentication
but the cookie authentication there is
different from the cookie authentication
i'm using in the other part of the site
there's a stupid guy on stage saying
that i should have a bunch of different
no i didn't say that but it opens up a
bunch of flexibility that you can do
different things
it also means there's a map when where
you can do your own predicates and you
can have a little function that actually
evals whether or not to use this other
pipeline so it doesn't only have to be a
url you can actually go in and say if
this user happens to be deluxe or some
fantastic user that has paid you a
trillion dollars he gets a different
pipeline
i don't know why that would be useful
but it's kind of it could be
um
but yeah i think it's pretty cool
but
what about old stuff
what if i come now into asp.net decor
and i look at this and i go oh i have
this awesome middleware i wrote a year
ago in project katana can i plug this in
here
yeah
it's the answer to that
it's not a good answer it's not swedish
it's not even close
yes you can but you can't plug it in as
a middleware
you can't throw it into this middleware
pipeline and say here is another
middleware because your old middleware
will expect an i dictionary and this
thing will give it an http context so
you're going to go ahead and go and you
you suck and it's going to start the
pipeline
so what you need to do is you need to
have a different way of doing owen
owen middlewares from project katana or
other owen stuff
and the way to do that i actually i i
just happen to have
a project
with a middleware in it so i'm just
going to go add
existing project
it's going to put me in here
there's a simple
owen based project katana based
middleware owen own way of doing things
i can take that
but i can't plug that in because that
middleware as i said is different so
what we need to do is we need to go in
here and say
project.json
and do
microsoft with the capital k a capital m
uh asp.net core
owen
100.
having that in there means that i can
then go back in and say somewhere in
here let's actually do it here because
the the middleware i want to plug in is
an exception handler delegate so i
actually want to i'm going to remove
that thing because that is way too fancy
for me
app.use owen
it gives me a pipeline
that pipeline is awesomely enough an
action of funk or funk of i dictionary
thread i'm not even going if you look at
the length of the signature of that
thing just ignore it it's this function
so if you go pipeline like that it gives
you a whole new set of weird things
what you're getting here is kind of that
mid-funk version
but the mid funk expects sort of like
inline function it doesn't expect
classes like we do our middlewares so
what we do is we say next
with the fat arrow
and then we say new and the name of my
that my
middleware was
something awesome debug error handler
middleware so new debug
error
debug error
yeah
if i
normally
oh yeah in core that's not handled for
me by
resharper
properly so that's the one
there it is so i create one of those and
that one expects a reference to the next
thing which is going to be next
and then it i return the invoke method
does that make sense
you guys are way smarter than i am
um okay so once i've got that i need to
throw an exception somewhere to get this
to work
so i'm gonna go down here and say throw
new exception
because that's one cool thing if you
throw exceptions without some form of
exception handling middleware
the pipeline just swallows it it doesn't
break your debugger it doesn't give you
any info well it does give you logging
but it just swallows it and doesn't
break visual studio or anything like
that and go into debugging it just goes
and it just gives you 500 back
so i'm going to throw a new exception
i'm going to add something i'm going to
say it's
glenn's fault
if
anybody wants to know who glenn is his
name glenn condren his pm on
dot net core team
it's his fault everything is his fault
we start that
and this might work it might not work
because it's been slightly flaky on me i
hope this works now
okay didn't break because i'm now in nbc
right so i'm throwing after nvsa so
let's go and break something here
hope didn't work
need to
force this thing to recompile properly
let's see if i can get it work now
i figured out that it's actually a yeah
it's a compile issue it doesn't get
updated code for some reason doesn't
recompile properly
so i've got this error handler thing now
that will now give me it will tell me
that something went wrong and it's going
to tell me this glance fault it's going
to give me a stack trace and it's also
going to give me a link to a stack
overflow with the error message if i
click this i'm pretty sure stack
overflow won't tell me why it's er
gland's fault but it should
so that's kind of cool right
easy to plug in old owen stuff as well
so i'm
yes
that's the thing mvc will say i can't
handle it go to the next guy
anything that mvc doesn't have a
response for will just go on through the
pipeline
so you won't get 404s you could probably
configure it or you actually if you if
you don't have anything after mvc
they i think the pipeline will actually
go 404 because there's nothing answering
it
so
this was kind of the end of things but
i have some extra stuff that i want to
show i'm going to go completely freak
out and show you weird things and give
you some ideas of things you can do with
om pipeline
one question one comment i get is that
the whole how do you do error handling
i'm using that om pipeline my my debug
error handler blah blah blah
if you don't want to go this big and
have your own middleware and everything
and just want to do it for debugging
purposes for some reason you can
actually go it's actually quite easy
this is kind of a cool way this is
something that's easy to throw in for
dev you go app.use
ctx
oh
a sync
ctx
next
do a one of those
then you do it try since this is all
code right we can put try catching here
so we can just do await
next
and then if that blows up i can go and
say console.
right line
error
or that's that's gonna be easy to find
an output right
h5 that
go to some weird location
it goes there right
so since the pipeline as i said is just
a matter of code and methods calling
methods
we can add try catch stuff anywhere in
it because since it's russian doll and
not like a linked list it basically it
means that i'm pushing things in and
when something breaks it bubbles up and
i can handle it wherever i want and then
here i can say try catch if it blows up
change it to a 500 and here is my
awesome content for my 500 error page or
i can create a redirect or something
creating redirect however is a bit of a
pain
because as long as the exception is
thrown
this is bad this was my last piece of
paper and it doesn't include words let's
show you now this is going to be
interesting um
yeah it will be fine i think i can use
that one um
how's doing something about it bubbling
up
yeah reader x thanks sorry i'm i'm
losing myself reader x is a pain in the
butt because as long as your your
exception is thrown before anything is
written to the pipeline which i do here
everything is fine in my exception and
error handling middleware i can change
it to redirect and change the headers
and all of that but if the exception is
thrown after the response or during the
response as soon as somebody has written
something to the pipeline i'm actually
written to the response i am too late
because it has already sent all of it so
it has already sent a to http 200 and
probably partial response and then it
blows up and i'm sitting there going you
just sent an http 200 and half of your
content and now you're coming telling me
that you made something wrong
douchebag
so we need to sort that out and there
are a couple of ways of doing it this is
done internally you can actually buffer
the response
which is a neat way of doing it
so if we take this thing
and we can buffer the response let's try
and do it here let's do var
ms equals new memory
memory
stupid that's
it doesn't get better
sounding like you you've got something
wrong in your head that apparently
doesn't make your spelling better var
response
equals ctx dot response
dot body
ctx dot response dot body equals
ms
see what i've done then
i actually create a another stream
and add that to the body so whenever
anybody in a middleware after this
starts writing to the stream they're
actually writing to the memory stream
and not to the actual server stream so
nothing is going to get re get written
and then i can go down here and what i
do here is i say
something brilliant like
i had code for this to remember what i'm
supposed to do
let's do
ms
let's see if this works
ctx dot response dot body equals
response
and then do
ms dot copy to async
response
and await that thing
so that means that basically if if
everything goes fine i'm going to copy
everything from
there it is that's the one that i miss
zero
comma and there so i basically i take
the memory stream that they've written
to i run that back to the beginning and
then i take all of the information in
that memory stream and i pass it to the
the real response and that gets rendered
but if something goes wrong
i can go in here and say
nah actually let's put it back the body
back properly
like that but then let's do ctx dot
response dot write async make that a
wait
you caused an
error
stop
ruining my website
and then return
make sense
run this
that works
and that now buffers it so even if i yes
oh yeah this is this is crap from a
memory point of
view yeah i i i was going to come to
that i was going to say that there are
there are issues with this and i
wouldn't recommend doing it all the time
um yes there are
four sort of
kind of ish obvious reasons
there are memory issues with this
because one when you write to the
response stream that you get from the
server it's actually not being buffered
it goes straight through clients it
doesn't stick in memory this thing is
going to make that every single request
to your web application will be stored
in memory as a string buffer before it's
being sent out
and it gets even worse if you do it like
this because the memory stream without
actually being initialized with a
specific size will do a whole bunch of
weird things to resize it and everything
once it grows beyond the existing size
and things like that so there are there
are definitely this is a demo right you
need to do it better than this you need
to show me show me up and go i know that
sucks i'm going to do this better and
prove me wrong but yes there are many
problems but it also gives me the
ability to do something really cool
which i've done a few times i can take
this code
i'm going to make a few tweaks to it i'm
going to do that but i'm going to cut
that out
there
not do that
and then i'm gonna turn that back i'm
gonna blah blah blah blah i'm gonna do
that and then i'm gonna let's see here i
have code for this i should know this
var actually let's do it no let's do it
like this
var response equals
response
text equals and coding
dot u t
utf8 dot get string
from
ms.2 array
like that
response text equals response
text dot
replace
replace hello i'm in australia so i've
heard that it's all great down here
right and then you go and take that and
you say await
ctx dot response dot
write async response
text
run your application
that is not what you want to see but
that's temporary until it boots up
properly
it works um you can go in and buffer
everything that goes out and make
changes to it
not not recommended for something really
big or really complicated and there are
memory issues with it and there's
another problem with this is that
there's actually another request coming
in here going to favicon.ico
that's not a problem right now but
if i was serving up images and stuff
like that as well and i tried to read
that as a utf stream and then go in and
replace stuff with it that would be bad
so you don't want to do that
and also one one thing to note is
if you're serving up static files that
is not handled by the pipeline to begin
with so if you want to serve up static
files you need to get another middleware
called static files
and go app.use static files and then it
will serve static files out of the dub
dub dub root folder of your project
if you want to change it you can
actually tell it to serve up the files
from some completely different place
like a network drive or something like
that and you can also tell it what urls
to respond to and things like that
so
i've used all the memes i could find
kind of sorry about that
hope we can still be friends i'm not a
big meme person normally but i needed
something my presentation was quite
boring otherwise
so i just want to thank everyone for
coming it's been awesome presenting i
hope you got something out of it that
you can use
if you're more interested in more
information about owen you can obviously
go to this url here and you can watch my
course on pluralsight on owen
and get lots more information and give
me money which is good you always want
to give me money it's a good thing
and if you don't you're not a member of
pluralsight they might have those trial
cards i understand if not hit me up i'll
get you one i've got one in my bag or a
couple of my bags so you can have a look
at my course you only get a free trial
pass if you watch my course at least
four times
thank you everyone it's been awesome